[Music]
on the 1st of april this video filmed by
a ukrainian soldier emerged it appears
to show dead bodies in the street of
butcher a town north of kiev
president zielenski accused russia of
committing war crimes in the town
but the kremlin has claimed the scenes
in the town were staged and cynical
ukrainian propaganda
by analyzing satellite imagery taken on
the 19th of march it's clear the bodies
have been lying in the open for weeks
and critically during the time russian
forces occupied the town
we've compared the satellite imagery and
ukrainian soldiers video
by highlighting bodies seen on the
street it's clear they're in the same
locations in both the video and the
satellite imagery
the images show bodies on yablonska
street a suburban road in the south of
butcher
in several shots from the video shapes
that appear in the satellite imagery
correspond to where bodies were found
after the russians retreated
these high-resolution images discredit
claims the bodies were planted after the
russian withdrawal and contribute to
mounting evidence that the kremlin has
potentially committed war crimes in the
conflict